Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Hace unos meses fui a una fiesta.
Era en la casa de un chico de la escuela
y fui con unos amigos
de la división a ver qué onda.
La fiesta estaba buena.
Había buena música,
no había demasiada luz,
y conocí a bastante gente;
era un lindo ambiente.
Al rato, nos acercamos a hablar
con unos conocidos de mis amigos
y vi a alguien que me gustó.
No le presté mucha atención al principio,
pero después me le acerqué a hablar
porque era la única persona
que no conocía a nadie.
Me atrajo su buena onda y facilidad
para sacar tema de conversación
y pasamos juntos lo que
quedaba de la fiesta.
La persona que conocí era Juan.
Esa noche, cuando volví a mi casa,
tenía una ensalada en mi cabeza.
Porque nunca antes me había pasado
esto de relacionarme con un chico.
Yo cuando voy a una fiesta no voy
pensando con quién me voy a relacionar.
Sino, lo que busco
es pasarla bien y disfrutar.
Sin embargo, no pensé que
me podría llegar a gustar.
Porque no era típico para mí.
Iba en contra de lo que
me salía naturalmente.
También esa noche tenía varias
preguntas en mi cabeza.
Por ejemplo: ¿cuáles son los criterios
que tenemos en cuenta
al momento de determinar
si nos gusta alguien o no?
¿Su físico? ¿Su género? ¿Su personalidad?
¿Una combinación de características?
Tampoco tenía muy en claro por qué
me estaba haciendo estas preguntas.
Si con cosas bastante similares
estas dudas no tenían lugar.
Porque no había respuesta a ellas.
Como ¿por qué me gustan tanto
las milanesas?
¡No lo sé! Me gustan y listo.
Toda esta situación,
preguntas, respuestas,
me llevó a pensar en dos cosas.
La primera, ¿por qué
tenemos la necesidad
de encasillar a las personas
en cuanto a su físico,
su género, su personalidad,
su intelecto?
Segundo, ¿cómo es que nos llega
a gustar alguien por estas cualidades?
No lo tengo muy en claro.
Pero creo que funcionamos
como una especie de filtros
que van marcando lo bueno y lo malo
de una persona
respecto de nuestro criterio.
Concluí después de mucho tiempo
que ese criterio, para mí,
era simplemente si me gustaba su persona
y si me sentía cómodo a su lado.
No me importaba quién es esa persona.
Tampoco me importaba qué le gustaba,
si era hombre, mujer,
o lo que sea.
Si esa persona gustaba de mí
y yo gustaba de esa persona
no había nada más por qué preocuparse.
Yo veo la orientación sexual
no como un género de preferencia
sino al conjunto de filtros
con el que cada uno elige.
No existe para mí tal cosa como ser gay,
heterosexual, pansexual, bisexual,
porque el concepto de género
no lo entiendo.
No entiendo qué es lo que te hace hombre
o qué es lo que te hace mujer.
Por lo tanto, tampoco entiendo
tu sexualidad como se la suele conocer.
Aunque sigue siendo difícil para
nosotros determinar nuestros gustos.
Y eso ¿por qué?
Porque la idea del amor
en este sistema social
en el que vivimos y nos relacionamos
es estar casados a eso de los 30,
una relación monogámica,
con una pareja de tu sexo opuesto,
con dos hijos
--un hijo mayor, una hija menor--
eso es lo que se nos inculca
consciente e inconscientemente
a cada uno de nosotros.
Y no seguir lo que profundamente
a cada uno nos gusta.
Estos filtros fueron cambiados,
modificados, e incluso flexibilizados
gracias a que tuvieron
el lugar de ser replanteados
a lo largo de la historia.
Creo que vivimos en un momento
muy particular
en el que existe no solo un replanteo
amplio sino profundo de estos filtros.
Y también la disminución de aquellos
que fueron impuestos por alguien más
además de Uds. mismos.
Lo veo todos los días.
En la calle, en las marchas,
en la escuela,
¡y eso es algo buenísimo!
Porque cada vez somos más
los que pensamos así.
Y eso es una continuación por una lucha
por el libre derecho
de la expresión sexual.
Y me pasa esto:
Yo el filtro género, no lo tengo presente.
Y puede que de acá a 5, 10, 20 años,
no lo tengan muchas más personas.
Si este filtro no existiese
en la cabeza de nadie más
entonces problemas actuales graves
no tendrían lugar,
como la discriminación, la desigualdad,
y la inequidad de derechos
por ser quien sos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)